a few years
ago I suddenly had a lot of extra time
to spend staring out the window maybe
you did a little bit of that too in
quarantine at the start of the
pandemic and while we were locked down I
got kind of fascinated with what was
still moving out
there like the local
crows who went on with their normal
commute down the side of the mountain
every morning
and up again every evening at Crow
quitting
time Birds of Prey came out every day
and made their
rounds I'm using a process here called
photo stacking where you take multiple
pictures from a fixed point over time
and layer them into one composite
photograph photo stacking is a way to
show the trails of things like stars
fireflies a athletes airplanes pretty
much anything that moves it's a way to
make the shape of those movements
visible most of these have between 500
and 2,000 layers they take a long time
to build and a lot of that time is spent
just experimenting with which layers to
keep in and which to leave out of the
final
image here a group of pelicans came in
from one side and noticed something
intriguing in the water
then another group came in from the
other side and circled around to check
it out so this isn't one moment Frozen
in Time like a traditional photograph
but something more like a story told in
two Dimensions with layers of the fourth
dimension kind
of looking at flight Trails this
way you really notice some of the
rhyming patterns that repeat everywhere
in nature like waves of sound or water
or spiraling galaxies whirlpools and
storms and sometimes they seem to sort
of sketch out other things that are
usually invisible to
us like the thermal updrafts that Hawks
and vultures ride on finding even the
smallest patches of turbulence in the
air to carry
them while I was working on these I
learned that some vultures are so good
at this that they can soar that way
without flapping their wings at all for
hours which has to be the most
meditative way there is to look for
carry
in and this is what it looks like to
navigate by
shouting bats are characterized as
either Whisperers or shouters and we're
lucky that the range of our hearing ends
right about where their voices begin
because the shouts can get up to 140 DB
as loud as a jet
engine what we call silence is just the
limit of our hearing I love to think
about that and about how most other
creatures from European moles to Rainbow
Trout find their way by wavelengths of
light or sound or fields of electricity
or magnetism that our senses just aren't
set up
for and that those are just the ways
that we know
about in the 1930s the British
ornithologist Edmund Salo studied flocks
of Starlings moving as if they had one
mind and wrote a book on his conclusion
that the birds must be
psychic and you know there's still no
evidence that they're not but we now
know that they follow each other with a
split-second lag time that's just too
short for our human sense of
time and maybe for some predators like
the paragan Falcon in the middle
there so these are pictures of group
decisions made at a speed that makes
them invisible to us pictures of the
Hidden intelligence in what might look
at first random or even
chaotic reminders that the Universe
isn't built to our measure but operates
on systems beyond our
perception that what we call empty air
is anything but empty if you're a bat it
holds the sound of the shape of a
hillside it's also a map of magnetic
signals and electrical
fields and a Topography of the smells of
krill patches and planked in
blooms we humans have invented whole
digital worlds but sometimes we still
need to be reminded that there's more in
this Heaven and Earth than is dreamt of
in our
philosophy and that there are endless
ways to look at familiar
sites like a bird in flight
with fresh
eyes to expand our shared experience in
a way that connects us with the rest of
the Living
World to feel both kinship with our
fellow creatures and respect and even
reverence for their
otherness in the words of the poet and
naturalist Jared K
Anderson bats can hear shakes
plants can eat light bees can dance
Maps we can hold all these ideas at once
and feel both heavy and weightless with
the Absurd beauty of it
all thank
you